a lot of people ask me if rubbing
stretches your skin and yeah it does a
little bit but so does slapping and it
probably doesn't make a difference there
are so many other things that we do in
our everyday life where we stretch our
skin way more and our skin is made to
stretch the most stretchy thing you
probably do to your face on a regular
basis is if you're a side sleeper then
you smush your face sideways into a
pillow for about eight hours a day there
are these things called Sleep lines but
they only show up when you're about 40
and so that's over 10 years of smushing
your face into a pillow even then it
only shows up because your collagen and
elastin the stretchy things in your skin
are degraded by things like growing old
and also UV exposure so unless you're
rubbing your skin really really hard for
over eight hours a day it probably isn't
worth worrying about how you apply a
product doesn't make a big difference to
how well it works based on Decades of
drug delivery research the most
important things are the chemical
properties of the active ingredient and
the formula so rubber Chopper Pat it
slap it it's probably fine